something I've been thinking about a lot
it's this notion of the clouds in the
third it's kind of like another version
of my stake in the sizzle meaning I
don't spend any time on the things that
don't matter and what doesn't matter is
basically everything in between the
overall vision and strategy and the real
knowledge of 'never cotton fabrics this
average will whatever happen if I got
mad at risk
I fully believe I am bought in that
there's an article hi here I don't need
the reports I don't need Neal since I
don't need seven years later evil I can
do something nice for somebody just
based on what being a nice dream in
return right then that wouldn't be a
cool world but the truth is the best
relationships are the ones where you
give them something and then you start
forming a relationship that that made a
venue somewhere along the line you got
so when I say the clouds and dirt my
clouds are I'm gonna buy the Jets and
here's how I'm going to do it that's a
global clouds injure here's my clouds
and dirt right now as wearing my
vaynermedia hat all the time like I
believe that the attention of the
consumer is on social networks from a
better value proposition than it is on
other places I like seeing something
using it and then making my the reason I
a lot people like make your predictions
are right unlike because they already
happened right when I'm good at is
seeing something happen use it use it
fast and then talk about it because I
believe right I didn't predict that vine
was gonna do well I saw that vine was
doing well I spent a lot of time
learning it and then I talked about it
do I think that billboards dead no I
don't but I also think that as I look at
all these people they're looking at
their phone right and so I don't think
it's worth as much
how can a billboard be worth the same
price today than it was five years ago
in a world where every person here when
they leave this conference when they go
under car if they're a passenger is
looking at their phone the entire time
until they get to wherever they're
getting and they're not seeing that
billboard and it's a matter of fact not
only the passenger my friends the driver
it's scary no I actually have reverted
back to driving with two hands because
I'm so scared of you jerk-offs because
every time I look to see how many people
are looking at billboards what I'm
really realizing is forget about
billboards nobody's looking at the
[ __ ] Road so my philosophy is social
media marketing works what you don't
have to do it and that's the clouds D I
don't think I'm really that talented in
most things the only talent that I think
really over indexes for me when it comes
to business is truly understanding that
innovation has never cared about anybody
entrepreneurs and CEOs and individuals
make the mistake of being either
romantic or naive to what's actually
happening around them and so what you're
going to see and what I'm banking on for
my career over the next 40 years is the
emergence of direct to consumer brands
that have been able to take advantage of
the reality of technology but not be
held down by the channel conflict of the
scale that they're at and be able to
grow into big businesses that go direct
to consumer and then the dirt is the
fact of like all of this that we do that
I do put out the content that I do
understand what dark posts are that I
understand you know that we're talking
now about you know Pinterest new ad
product that I know the details the holy
grail of creating the strategy of the
long tail algorithm search queries to
target to the amplification of the
creative we create done best is testing
a lot of things for first 30-60-90 and
we're trying to figure out what those
days where we are it's so early right
now the real true d our product in the
world
and so I believe that engagement at on
Twitter makes sense
I also better do it I mean all the
people like you know it's not about what
you say it's about engagement all these
people that you know like have their
strategy on it social like the map
social media gurus that are like make
sure you engage and they don't engage at
all
great so hypocrisy that's why I built
the company that I built and not a VM
I'm using the variable conversion is the
cream and that is ID that is human IP a
lot of times people don't have one or
the other they're too stuck in the
minding sure they don't see the bigger
picture they don't know how to navigate
for they get it philosophically but then
on the skills or the appetite or the
want or need to actually be able to do
it right you know please me queasy and
lost my rise over all all the way or
shittin van and Anjali is striking and
my guess is its Allah know the details
know the philosophy and don't worry
about all the Myesha in the middle the
politics the process that all the crap
does not
matter that's it you spent all my time
the cloud senator and that's why I think
I'm successful I play at extreme levels
of a high by N and then dedication to
learning my craft clouds